what it do everybody my name is ross
panetta chef and owner of fire kitchen
and this is celebrity recipe royale
where we take recipes from our favorite
celebrities
and they battle it out to see which one
is the best on today's lineup we have
dan levy ashley benson snooki
and the god himself gordon ramsay i
measured out the ingredients as each
recipe stated
and i found three pizza lovers to tell
me figure out which one of their pizzas
is the best
so which one of these celebrities has
the best pizza recipe it's about to get
wild
saucy up in here so first up to the ring
we have dan
levy we're going to start off by slicing
some red onions real thin
and put that to the side dan levy uses a
pre-made cauliflower crust pizza
and to that we're going to massage in
some garlic and olive oil
after that we're going to spoon over
some vodka sauce spread it out to a
really thin and even layer
we're going to sprinkle some mozzarella
cheese and shred over some gruyere for
some extra kick
next up he tops it off with sliced red
onions sopra satna
some capers and a drizzle of olive oil
we're going to throw that into a 425
degree oven until nice and golden brown
and there you have it dan levy's
cauliflower crust pizza
that is crazy this actually looks
bang bang this smells just like a
regular pizza
never had capers before so we'll see how
this goes i'm not against a thin crust
but like
this is mega thin
[Music]
not bad but definitely not what i was
expecting it's good it's fine
the biggest takeaway was definitely the
sauce tastes like a vodka sauce i assume
it is
cheese is good i like the addition of
the onions not the biggest fan of this
crust
presentation wise not the prettiest
overall it's got
some really good flavors going on but
the crust isn't quite doing it for me
so next up we have actress ashley benson
we're going to start off by tearing up
all the mozzarella cheese in the world
and setting that to the side in a
separate bowl we're going to put
together our white sauce
we're gonna measure out some ricotta
cheese the juices of two lemons
a wide amount of salt some pepper we're
gonna get mixy with it
we're gonna slice up some brussels
sprouts and put that to the side on a
clean sheet tray we're gonna oil it up
so it don't stick
chop up some garlic and we're gonna
spoon over our sauce
we're gonna throw over our tornado
mozzarella cheese throw on some red
onions some garlic
we're gonna crack two yolks before we
put it in a 475 degree oven for about 10
minutes
once the pizzas came out the oven you're
going to top it off with your brussels
sprouts
some arugula and there you have it
ashley benton's
white pizza oh all right damn
this is what i'm talking about that's a
thick crust i saw a little jiggle in
there looks like it might be some egg
this is definitely not the traditional
pizza but i'm down
to try new things mmm
that's on the money that is very good if
you're like feeling healthy
this is for you for a white pizza that
little addition of the egg
definitely elevated it very rich very
filling i think i could eat about one
slice of this and be
ready to pass out personally if i'm
gonna eat pizza i want pizza
but this is good there's absolutely
nothing wrong with this the first time i
had arugula on pizza and it was quite a
pleasant surprise i gotta say so next up
we have jersey shore's beloved snooki
she's gonna start off by spraying a cast
iron pan with cooking spray do not
at me it was not my call to spray the
pan it's a part of the recipe
she's gonna throw in her pre-made crust
on a medium-low flame spread
over some pizza sauce throw in some
mozzarella cheese and top it off with
some pepperoni we're going to cover that
pan with a lid
and boom there you have it snooki's
skillet style pizza
definitely have something a little more
traditional here it looks really nice
and saucy
when i think pizza i always always
always go for some pepperoni
sauce is super flavorful i'm not super
impressed with the crust
nothing wrong with it you can't really
mess up pepperoni pizza too badly
this has very much of a taste of um
something that you'd slap in a toaster
oven
you could tell me that this one was like
store-bought and i believe you
if someone served this to me at a
restaurant i'd be a little pissed
it's good pizza but again crust is a
little thin
and now the recipe y'all been waiting
for gordon ramsay we're going to start
off by making some dough in a bowl we're
going to throw in one packet of yeast
warm water a couple tablespoons of sugar
and let that get activated
in a separate bowl we're going to sift
out some flour make a well in the middle
add a couple tablespoons of olive oil
and throw in our yeast mixture
we're gonna form a dough and keep
kneading until all the dough from the
sides are scraped off
we're gonna form the dough into a ball
throw it in a bowl
and cover with a towel and let it rise
so once the dough has risen
we're gonna deflate it like brady's
football we're gonna split the dough
into two pieces
spread out the dough put it in an oil
cast iron pan on a medium to low flame
spoon over some tomato pasada some torn
mozzarella
until the bottom is cooked we're gonna
throw it into a 475 degree oven
once the pizza comes out the oven gordon
is gonna top it off with some fresh
rosemary
and there you have it gordon ramsay's
homemade margarita pizza
this looks like a traditional pizza this
one might be
it the melted cheese looks beautiful
that's amazing holy cow that fresh
mozzarella
super soft this tastes like good pizza i
would get this at a pizza shop in new
york you can tell the ingredients from
the dough
to the sauce that's used to the cheese
are all very high quality
this is very good and you should
definitely make this at home or go out
to a pizza shop
and expect to get this super simple but
at the same time
super tasty so which one of these celebs
has the best homemade pizza
we're about to find out my absolute
favorite had to be number four
it was a traditional new york slice of
pizza as a new yorker
i'm partial it was delicious the sauce
was great cheese was great
and the crust was perfect gordon ramsay
all right
all right gordon i see you my favorite
has to be number two
the ingredients were to die for the
richness of the egg
really brought something that i'd never
really experienced with pizza before
ashley benson okay she knows how to make
a great pizza i have to say
that the one that i liked the most was
definitely
number four we had that fresh mozzarella
that fresh sauce
even the dough itself was super like
light and airy and it just seemed
extra extra extra fresh gordon ramsay my
guy i knew it i could always depend on
my guy gordon ramsay to deliver an
awesome dish
so on this celebrity recipe royale
gordon ramsay takes the belt for his
homemade margarita pizza
which recipe do you think we should try
next leave a comment
below
[Music]
you